dans le palmarès des aliments qui sont
bons à s'en lécher les doigts les
comptes levés doivent arriver pas très
loin du sommet
les comptes le visa origines du sud des
états unis les premiers ports sont
arrivés au xviiie siècle donc on pense à
la barbecue bernd qu'il vaut du texas ou
du caroline et du kent au quai vers le
dip sens c'est pas non plus le barbecue
belle pour ariel accusé dans pioneer est
facile à faire dans cette région là
il ya juste deux saisons texan cet été
qui l'été prochain on peut manger dehors
toute l'année il ya beaucoup de
rassemblement familial sur le barbecue à
l'extérieur le port est une viande
maigre mais transformés en compte lever
il devient gras sucrés salés et
savoureux et facile t'as pas besoin de
l'assiette
se tient un repas plus festif on est
occupé à déguster à leurs gardes et à
voir si on reste encore sur
l'orthographe bien accepter que ça va
finir tout sur la table sur toi
autrefois offert surtout dans le
comptoir des surgelés les voici
principalement au rayon des produits
frais prêts à manger chez soi comme au
restaurant en passant du congélateur
vers le ferai ben il ya l'achat impulsif
on sait quand on arrive à la maison en
20 minutes c'est vrai il ya de multiples
raisons je sais la lame hélas il y en a
d'autres qui sont plus à la purée de
tomate la sauce traditionnel la source
de grands pas on veut dans toute une
romance autour de la sauce avec des
ingrédients spéciaux
l'épicerie analyse 17 produits dont les
prix varient de 1 dollar 50 à près de 4
dollars la portion de 140 g protéines et
au texas né et grandi au texas
gérard szaraz texan ainsi qui sert
justement beaucoup de côtes levées
me dis qu'ils n'ont jamais goûté aux
côtes levées du commerce n'ont jamais
une fois de ma vie la nutritionniste f
cryptée et le chef nick rage n'ont pas
hésité à se salir humains pour la cause
je suis 99 pour sa soeur que tout ça
c'est que sous vide axé sur certains cas
elles vont toutes être hard sur le
marché deux grandes catégories barbecue
et style tu exerces on bute d'abord à
cinq produits saveurs barbecue
traitantes mais j'ai ça l'est un nom est
ce que c'est ça le haut c'est juste moi
c'est sucré
j'ai déjà demandé et ce n'est pas le
plus à l'est d'autres comme choix du
président et saint-hubert le sont encore
plus
et moi je prends les petits mots
c'est aussi ça déchirait de l'os toute
chose c'est moins coûteux ça c'est juste
sucré très sucrée
[Musique]
mais je trouve en queue de cumin aussi
ses horaires
trop salé trop sucré plus balancée oui
dispo le montrant que j'ai plus est
c'est parti
carrément
c'est plus que l'autre ah bah je veux
pas juger mais c'est moins intéressant
le goûte plus tard le soir
c'est là que la maman était ma préférée
ou quoi c'est drôle quand même parce que
toi celle là c'est la moins jolie pl -
je suivais si ça de toutes celles qu'on
a analysées comme quoi ça pas besoin
d'être très salée prescrit pour être bon
goût on a remarqué que les produits de
la cage aux sports est plaisant
gastronomiques étaient ceux qui s'était
mis au niveau du sucre non vraiment
moins de sucre par portion parle de 7 à
8 g versus une vingtaine de grammes 25e'
plus pour ceux qui avaient le plus de
sucre
alors pour la ronde numéro 2 nous avons
donc trois styles texans
5 se sont aussi c'est plus vinaigrée que
se crée la sauce barbecue du texas mais
la sns sirop de maïs une association il
ya peu de sauce au texas qui sont pas
fini avec sa sweat-shirt et sauce
tabasco c'est vraiment remarquable
les tailles des produits je te laisse
quant à l'autre
donc petit cochon gros cochon
ils disent sauce barbecue fumer tue le
texan ici en bleu on a le parti
québécois le parc du québec qui est une
très bonne initiative que la cage a eu
d'ailleurs c'est drôle on voit le
stampede ici pour parler du tout peur
beau tout à l'heure la cage aux lancers
de ce produit l'année dernière autour de
la saint jean baptiste
du porc québécois pour la cage et du
porc canadien pour le choix du président
les deux étant les seuls à afficher
clairement qu'il s'agit de port d'ici
plaisirs gastronomiques et saint-hubert
utilise du porc provenant du rhin
[Musique]
on est sucré encore
c'est la sauce barbecue à la mode du sud
basse distingue pas beaucoup n'ont pas
détaillé m c'est alcoolisées ça
sébastien bourbon a
inscrit dans les sucre sucre cassonade
sirop d'érable miel mélasse sur certains
emballages on souligne la présence de
sirop d'érable au niveau du marketing
est certain qu'ils vont dire contre
l'avis l'érable mais quand on
s'attendait à ce degré bien b il ya
beaucoup plus que l'érable comme source
dessus on constate en effet la présence
de mélasse de purée de pommes de
cassonade ou de miel
ok il en restera un goûter les spéciales
spécial nouveau genre
j'aimerais mentionner les produits de
trois fois par jour qui lui sent
complètement de l'esthétique des
catégories et les fait pas super beau
non on a du plaisir tout en délicatesse
moins sucré
drôlement parce qu'il ya des treize les
belles dames mets sucrés quand même et
c'est intéressant je trouve que je ne
sais les choses qui sortent de leur part
s'ils le font pour le consommateur il ya
un autre produit qui est pas
nécessairement juste sucré tomates et
mais ce produit été le plus sali du
groupe avec 770 mg de sodium par portion
donc cage aux sports 2 étoiles dans le
bulletin
machine une préférence pour les
ingrédients plus courte
les finalistes sont donc plaisir
gastronomique parce qu'elles sont les
moins sucré de tout et pour leur courte
liste d'ingrédients et la cage pour leur
faible teneur en sucre et en sodium et
surtout pour le goût thé sucré secret
c'est la vie
[Musique]